now if I want to do this completely
scrappy how does it actually work to
help us y equals Slava blah blah blah
blah okay now we know that completing a
square it mainly focuses on one number
in this line which number is it which
sum is the most important number to
completing the square
it's going to be that guy right there
yeah it's the one where I have to have
it n square of 5 and square so I'm going
to go ahead and do that I'll stay with
this so you can see I've got let's bring
that subtraction of 7 into both sides to
get rid of all the right-hand side that
gets this guy in the focus and now I
will Harvard Square so what's the thing
I have to add to both sides for that
turns this into negative 3 now it turns
this into an to 1 you care that okay now
when you have a look at this on the
right hand side you get X minus 2 all
squared you hear that okay
now this form right here is useful
because it confirms what I saw up here
do you notice have a look at the numbers
look that tells you all this is where I
get the minimum and this tells you the
minimum itself but I want you to notice
it over here I write it with this 3 see
this guy I'm going to put it back over
the other side which is a bit weird but
you'll see why I'm doing like so ok see
that X minus 2 all squared X minus 2 all
squared because it's a square what is
the smallest value that that thing can
possibly take the smallest out the whole
thing something squared the small study
that a square can take is 0 right a
square can never be negative do you
agree at least of the number that we
deal with ok so therefore the minimum of
this is 0 so the minimum of the whole
thing is 0
three you see that so really what you're
telling me is that this is the number
that gives me the lowest of the total
because I consider it one object at a
time thus more this guy can be a zero
this or this greater B is three because
he's always three so therefore that's
the total it's the smallest okay and of
course you could repeat that logic in
Reverse if I happen to have a concave
down parabola okay all right does it
make sense
are you following so excuse me all you
have to do beyond this is when you give
it a question have you guys got your
textbook their keys you have a look at
arm this is a D which is one over on the
right hand side have a look at a
question like say skip all the way
across to question six question six so
this is on page 297 on the textbook I
don't know what is on the PDF now just
real with me take take 15 seconds to
actually read it to yourself now the
only question are rather the only skill
you need to demonstrate above what I've
just shown you is that all of this
assumes you already have some kind of
equation like this and then off you go
you just choose a method and you're done
if you have a look carefully at question
six you don't have better provide an
equation for you you have to make it up
yourself okay so let's actually just
quickly do this together a rectangle has
a perimeter of 16 meters I'm just going
to write down perimeter 16 metres and
what is it I'm trying to find what is it
I'm trying to maximize or minimize the
length of I'm looking for the maximum
area of this rectangle yeah so it's like
this is um this is your raw material
that you can make the edges out of I
want to make a really really big
rectangle into the area okay so I'm
trying to maximize area okay so to help
me it's not necessary but just like in
circulatory a diagram will help like so
they give you a bit of a hint
but they won't give you kids later on I
think they say let a site be X that's
what they say if this is X then what's
this site over here now that tells you
what these two sides have to be because
remember what your total is going to be
I think it's going to be 8 minus X isn't
it
have I done it right because when you
add them all up do you get 60 looks good
yet so now I can say my area equals this
by this and there's your quadratic now
being that this is what we've just
worked out which is the three methods do
you think is going to be the most
suitable I want the method that requires
the least amount of work have I maybe
already done one of these it's it's
already written in factorized form if
it's already factored out for you don't
worry about doing anything else
you've done all the legwork there's a
real zero a root of eight so now you
know where the maximum will occur it
will be at x equals halfway between
which is four which by the way will give
you what kind of rectangle which is not
a coincidence okay